jean-claude le président mitterrand a
visité tout à l'heure le chantier du
grand loup je vous rappelle que c'est en
1983 que le chef de l'état avait décidé
de confier à l'architecte sino-américain
monsieur you mean paye la responsabilité
de l'aménagement du grand lot et
monsieur p que nous allons retrouver
dans quelques instants et l'un des plus
grands architectes du monde et ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'il fait un musée
il a dessiné entre autres celui de
boston ainsi qu'une aile du musée
national de washington et en chine même
il a fait récemment un splendide hôtel
dans la banlieue de pékin est l'une des
caractéristiques de toutes ces
réalisations c'est l'harmonie entre la
tradition et la pancarte
voilà nous devrions retrouver maintenant
monsieur père et son fils pour deux
raisons parce que le fils de monsieur
paye travaille avec son père sur ce
projet pendant que son père est bien et
aux quatre coins du monde pour élaborer
d'autres d'autres projets comme celui-ci
où différents bien monsieur monsieur
paye fils lui reste ici messieurs vous
m'entendez bien bonjour alors là c'est
monsieur paye fils ou monsieur pays perd
alors le père est à droite et le fils et
à gauche pourrez pas vous tromper
bonjour messieurs bonjour alors je
voudrais m'adresser d'abord au père
monsieur paye le louvre n'est pas n'est
pas étranger pour vous parce que vous
avez habité en france il ya quand même
pas mal d'années à pouvoir faire baisser
je suis venu en france en 1950 ailleurs
et j'habitais justement dans un hôtel on
fasse tout près d'ici
vous aviez imaginé à l'époque de
travailler à la réfection ou à quelque
chose qui concerne le loup ou alors ça a
été une surprise quand le président vous
a sollicité
oui c'était super
sabrina
alors je considère que cette dame n'a
mais aussi un très grand défi est donc
j'ai pas accepté tout de suite
monsieur paye alors votre prénom ses 10
ans 10 10 10 mais c'est pas votre prénom
oui je connais pas l'eau alors je vais
vous appelez diddy a excusé jeudi c'est
le fils mais oui mais dites moi pourquoi
parlez-vous si bien le français votre
papa un petit peu moins j'ai appris le
français à l'école états unis ah bon
écoutez vous avez très bon professeur
alors une des spécialités de votre père
est donc vous monsieur paye c'est
d'allier une structure moderne à des
éléments anciens ça c'est ce qui a fait
votre réputation
mais est-ce que vous avez résolu ce
problème facilement en ce qui concerne
le louvre
alors avant de commencer alors j'ai lu
beaucoup de l'histoire de la france et
du bâtiment du lourd et après ça je me
sentais alors mieux équipés pour
attaquer ce problème
en fait je viens de quitter le président
de la république tout à l'heure et lui
il était en train de donner un discours
sur l'histoire du palais du louvre rien
monsieur pays pourquoi avoir pensé à une
forme de pyramide qui a surpris certains
français au début qui pour eux évoque
plus la culture égyptienne que français
rien à voir avec l'egypte c'est pas du 3
du tout égyptienne les craintes de la
profession et égyptienne j'ai donné mais
cette pyramide ci soit une pyramide en
verre tandis que les permis et jyp
sienne on s'entend en pierre
c'est fait pour la vie c'est fait pour
la lumière alors de quoi parle-t-on je
vous retrouve tout de suite messieurs
maintenant nous allons voir
et bien le la visite de ce chantier en
compagnie de patrice veulent et regardez
bien ce sont des images inédites
ils sont toujours là les fonctionnaires
du ministère des finances
retranché dans l'oeil richelieu est pas
près de déménager si l'on en croit
edouard balladur sous leurs fenêtres
l'un des plus grands chantiers de la
capitale des travaux dans la cour
napoléon depuis fin 85 lille 200
ouvriers organisé en trois huit et
aujourd'hui un projet qui sort de terre
avec pour le gros oeuvre à peine un mois
de retard au coeur du grand louvre la
pyramide de verre de l'architecte
américain paye une pyramide déjà célèbre
avant même d'être construite depuis
quelques semaines grâce à l'échafaudage
d'une vingtaine de mètres de haut
les visiteurs peuvent en mesurer le
volume mis en place des verrières dès le
mois de juin prochain
autre point chaud du chantier la
confection du plancher central en béton
blanc la perfection architecturale selon
paye une dalle coulé dans des caissons
en pin d'orégon selon une technique
américaine et des consignes très
strictes espadrilles obligatoire pour
tous les menuisiers
sous cette dalle sera installé l'accueil
central du grand louvre informations
boutique exposition un lieu de vie pour
les visiteurs chauffagiste peintre et
plombiers commenceront leurs travaux
d'ici 3 ou 4 mois en direction du
carrousel en revanche les travaux
progressent moins vite
seul émerge le gros oeuvre de la galerie
marchande souterraines
mais selon les ingénieurs du chantier
les promesses seront tenues livraison de
la pyramide et des espaces souterrains
au public pour le début 88
se posera alors une question plus
politique
comment dégager l'entrée richelieu
bloqué par le ministère des finances une
entrée indispensable à la bonne
circulation des visiteurs
voilà monsieur paix et vous êtes
optimiste à propos de la deuxième phase
des travaux vous vous sentez un peu gêné
la non dans votre projet je ne peux pas
répondre à cette question parce que ça
c'est une question politique intérieure
à la france
bon je vous ai je vais vous êtes très
diplomate monsieur paix oui mais vous
n'en pensait pas moins
bon alors je vais pas vous embêter avec
ça a eu une seule question qui va vous
paraître étrange est-ce que vous avez
est ce que vous aurez peut-être des
problèmes d'entretien pour cet immense
pyramide comment ça ce n'est toi comment
ça s'entretient
une chose pareille
à propos une crème pack civile il n'y a
pas de projet pareil dans le monde dont
je peux pas
vous donnez l'exemple quelque chose qui
est aussi un complexe que ça oui me
rassure et nous ça existera je veux dire
par là que vous allez imaginer quelque
chose pour entretenir cette cette
structure quand même nettoyage alors la
surface de verre est très petit
une personne vous nettoyez dans
deux-trois jours ont fait ce soit même
patricia une dernière chose monsieur p
je crois que pour cette pyramide vous
avez choisi des matériaux français
saint-gobain est ce pour des raisons
politiques ou est-ce que vous considérez
que ce sont les meilleurs matériaux du
monde pour cet objet précisément
politique c'est une question de
volonté et capabilités de saint gobain
de produits revers qui n'a pas de nom
pas de teint parfait monsieur paix une
dernière question est ce que vous êtes
satisfait du travail de votre fils si
vous comprenez ce que nous disons quand
même vous comprenez le français avoue le
parler aussi
vous voyez vous êtes deux fois content
parce qu'il fait du bon travail et puis
parce qu'il parle français et vous
monsieur paye vous est tout le temps sur
le chantier là je m'adresse à 10 10
je suis là alors en france mais vous
représentez votre père vous vous
participez d'une autre manière aux
travaux alors je fais partie de notre
équipe d'architectes qui ces appareils
très bien bien messieurs je vous
remercie et puis bonne chance à ce
chantier envoie merci beaucoup